Global arms sales grew again last year
for the seventh year in a row that's
according to secrete the Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
its annual report for 2021 says weapon
sales were up despite Supply change
challenges amid the pandemic so sales by
the top 100 companies in the industry
reached
592 billion dollars that's an increase
of almost two percent on the previous
year U.S companies again dominated the
list with nearly 300 billion dollars of
arms sales but that was a drop of almost
one percent on 2020 blamed mainly on
inflation now China meanwhile boosted
its arms sales by more than six percent
to 109 billion dollars for Chinese
companies are ranked in the top ten and
then there's Russia who sales Rose to
17.8 billion dollars but that was only
up 0.4 on 2020 and that of course was
before it invaded Ukraine now experts
expect the war to add two supply chain
woes for the arms industry
well to talk more about the findings
from the C3 report I'm joined by Lorenzo
scarazzotto from the C3 Institute he's
in Stockholm welcome to DW Lorenzo um
now firstly what do you make of how
little Russian arm sales Rose in 2021
just before it attacked Ukraine
well it has been an ongoing Trend we've
seen Russian companies stagnating at
least since 2016. and to the point that
the Kremlin issued a statement
encouraging companies to diversify their
production to enter the civilian market
and become profitable again
we've also seen companies being deep in
debt and the Russian government had to
bail them out multiple times 2016 17 19
and again 2020. uh therefore yes it's
been an ongoing Trend we believe the
civilian production in defense companies
will now be uh
reduce or at least shut down but again
uh we have to see what's the effect of
the sanctions but also the supply chain
production uh it has been an ongoing
struggle for the Russian defense
industry to produce what was needed at
the front line we've seen it using uh
missiles you thought to to deliver
warheads and they've been using that for
conventional Warfare so yes I remains to
be seen but it has been an ongoing and
ongoing trend Lorenzo what about
worldwide how much is the war in Ukraine
actually affected demand
well our data is actually referring to
2021 but we are likely we are going to
see an increase in armed sales that's
that's very very much Pro uh since the
Cold War European countries were
expecting a different kind of warfare
low intensity and possibly asymmetric
the war in Ukraine has real no change
change this perception uh sending
weapons to Ukraine is gonna from is
going to create a demand and we have to
differentiate this demand we have on one
hand the demand stemming from
replenishing stockpiles and that is not
likely to tip the scales Legacy weapon
systems are usually cheaper and there's
not going to make the difference on the
long term what is likely to to make the
difference are the more advanced systems
such as the 35s we've seen Germany Czech
Republic even Greece interest in these
systems however this is gonna this is
going to take time companies are waiting
before ramping up production they are
waiting to see a contract signed they
they they want to make sure there is
going to be an increased and consistent
demand across across time so yes we we
probably see an increase in long term
we've seen an increase now even with the
pandemic and the Fallout of the pandemic
um I want to talk about China Lorenzo um
because they've been pouring money into
their weapons industry and of course
this is against the backdrop of those
increasing tensions over Taiwan can you
tell us a little bit more about China
and and the situation there
sure China has eight companies in the
top 100 and four in the top ten China
has been a major player in arms industry
for a number of years and the recent
increase is probably due to the fact
that they're not affected by supply
chain issues the supply chain is local
and it has been local for uh for all the
region all Asian cyanes trying to find a
domestic and autonomy in armed
production again ramping up production
takes time and we've seen China ramping
a production consistently in across
years at least since the 90s what's very
relevant in the in this year is that
we've seen the military shipbuilders the
first in the world the biggest in the
world being created from two existing
companies in China
Lorenzo scarazzotto from The cypri
Institute in Stockholm thank you
thanks for having me